[Musique]
c'est une année qui commence fort pour
elie semoun alors que l'humoriste avait
l'intention de souhaiter une bonne année
à ses abonnés de façon humoristique
instagram n'a visiblement pas saisi
l'humour de l'artiste qui a été censuré
à deux reprises un message dans lequel
il commençait par faire des excuses à
plusieurs communautés
je vais m'excuser aussi auprès de la
communauté noire musulmane et juive
j'ai dérapé avant de conclure par aller
saluer
pardon je m'excuse auprès de la
communauté homosexuelle ont une manière
pour lui de jouer sur la censure et la
liberté d'expression qui est de plus en
plus mises à mal dans la société et avec
cette censure instagram prouve que la
liberté d'expression n'est en tous les
cas pas un de ses points forts sur son
compte l'artiste s'est étonné de la
réaction du réseau social c'est bien la
première fois qu'on me censure pour une
vidéo où justement je me moque du
ridicule et du pathétique de devoir
m'excuser pour ça avant de poursuivre je
ne comprends plus rien à cette époque de
coincer et de psychorigide et de crétin
qui prennent tous au premier degré la
tyrannie de la bêtise nous en veille
alors êtes vous choqué par la censure
des vidéos d'elie semoun
personnellement je suis extrêmement
choquée et lycées uni da ilha il a
rigolé de tous pendant depuis les années
en plus ça aide c'est incroyable pour
moi c'est extrêmement choquant 5 est
extrêmement choquant c'est que ces
réseaux alors au nom de quoi maintenant
c'est de la bonne parole déjà pour
commencer et surtout quand on voit tous
ceux qui sont harcelés
oui je suis en rien n'est pour fermer
les comptes ni pompes de nairas this man
ray du riz du tout est là on va quoi on
coupe le compte de ses mots non copains
on coupe le compte de bigard même même
trump je n'aime pas du tout jeune mais
pourquoi au nom de quoi on le coule son
compte c'est un vrai problème
non
vraiment une installation il faut couper
tous les messages homophobe raciste
antisémite à ce moment là parce que
30000 appelle les gens à l'étoile freud
c'est quand même le président des états
unis les mecs donc il a une bonne assise
c'est un truc c'est pas voilà moi je
suis choqué quand tu vois pas au nom de
quoi les réseaux sociaux maintenant dit
ce qui est bien et pas bien mais alors
j'attends vraiment la réaction des
téléspectateurs l'action des lycées moon
qui est avec nous salut mon dd d'amour
ça va mon chéri jusqu'à maintenant ça y
est tu es parti sur koh lanta du poteau
la jeune casser la gueule dans cette
gestion je suis bien je suis en
guadeloupe que j'ai cette chance je vais
jouer en martinique est bon en tout cas
ça doit très de quelques jours je te dis
c'est vrai que je suis ravi que je suis
ravi que on parle de ça parce que
honnêtement c'est vrai qu'il ya plus
grave dans la vie hein mais j'ai fait
cette vidéo en soutien à norman ans
celle qui agace gens qui a été obligé de
faire des excuses parce qu'il a fait une
blague sur la james bond girl and white
et justement il jouerait jurent qu'ils
soient reçus jeudi à quelque chose là
dessus c'est le nordmann c'était dans
son spectacle à norman bonjour c'est
incroyable le mec alors et c'est foods
et que ça sent plus non pas que je le
connais on le connaît norman est il
qu'il n'est pas du tout raciste ni
j'espère défendre du tout du tout bah
oui il s'est fait défoncer sur les jeux
c'est donc je me suis dit tiens je vais
faire un truc drôle nuancé où je vais
m'excuser auprès des communautés alors
que j'ai insulté personne évidemment
et c'était une façon pour moi de
ridiculiser ceux ce 7 jours sur 7 elle
cette censure est ce dont on est obligé
parce qu'on est obligés de faire serre
s'est excusé en permanence de se moquer
des gens et ce qui est fou c'est que
paradoxalement c'est les gens très
sympas premier degré c'est que les gens
de la communauté portugaise son show clé
les juifs les musulmans les [ __ ] alors
que c'est complètement à la rose est ce
que j'ai voulu faire je voulais dire un
truc sur eni il a dit tout à l'heure et
lyon il a démarré en disant il ya plus
grave
mais moi je trouve que justement ça
devient extrêmement gras dur parce que
ça révèle vraiment d'un climat dans
notre société est très grande et d'une
dictature mais que voilà bien de la rive
de la bien pour soi c est devenu
insupportable on peut plus rien faire
géraldine on m'a effectivement je pense
que c'est beaucoup plus grave
ouais est beaucoup plus effrayant parce
que l'on veut bien dire et je pense que
ce qui s'est passé là va se repasser à
bâcher de plus en plus regarder derrière
vos écrans de fumée sur netflix qui
explique exactement comment aujourd'hui
on est gangréné comment il ya un diktat
de la bien pensante et alors moi je suis
d'accord avec benjamin leyre qui va
dessiner
bah oui les gars et les grands manitous
dégâts face et qui a alors saisi aux
berbères qui va dire vous vous avez vous
avez droit
vous avez pas moi vous êtes bien
pensants vous vous êtes mal pensants
vous vous êtes haineux la seule règle
aujourd'hui c'est est ce qu'on est hors
la loi où est-ce qu'on est dans la loi
et moi je suis d'accord avec benjamin
trump je déteste tout ce qui est fait et
tout ce qu'il dit mais il faut pas qu'il
soit interdit
il faut juste qu'ils sont interdits par
ses électeurs et qui dégage et qu'on
n'entende plus parler mais pas par
zuckerberg qui doit décider quel est le
conduit brûler quelqu'un au delà de ça
au delà de ça c'est aussi l'influencent
2 il faut savoir y voilà et pardon il
faut savoir il faut savoir qu'ils
quittent eu censure
je veux dire les gens qui sont
réellement raciste et qui sont
réellement malveillants ok faut le faire
et des gars comme moi
c'est pas possible et c'est tellement
bête c'est ce que j'ai écris c'est la
tyrannie de la bêtise
maintenant les gens elle tout au premier
degré ils savent puisque c'est l'humour
enfin je veux dire moi quand j'ai
commencé à l'aider d'eau on avait une
affiche moi j'étais déguisé en inceste
et dieudo en cucs clan un truc pareil à
lhassa la capitale qatarie vous voyez
les spectacles voyez mes spectacles je
peux me faire mille procès mais j'en ai
jamais parce qu'on sait que surveillant
et on sait que je ne suis pas raciste je
dire c'est mais au contraire au
contraire choisir moi j'ai fait que j'ai
vu c'est grave mais c'est quand même
grave je crois qu'on a donné la parole
aux idiots et ils apprennent mois et des
mois je trouve ça extrêmement grave et
je vous dirai lit dans ses spectacles
comme le faisait des proches à l'époque
comme le faisait coluche comme le long
font plein d'humoristes au contraire et
lee il se sert de l'humour pour dénoncer
des choses et aujourd'hui ce qui va se
passer c'est qu'on voit des mecs qui
vont faire un humour
voilà au ras des pâquerettes parce que
ça formatés ça va du surgelé sanaa du
fait du sens non mais c'est vrai je
réponds sur le format qui prendre moi
j'ai rigolé quand j'ai vu la vidéo
j'étais mort de rire après quand j'ai
appris qu'elle est c'est censuré
germanier ou là en fait faut pas oublier
une chose c'est un humoriste lycées les
bien sûr c'est un humoriste aujourd'hui
toi chauffeur-livreur tu as le droit de
dire des conneries beaucoup plus grave
on ne dira rien tu peux faire des
chroniqueurs sur les plateaux de télé
des mecs qui parlent politique peuvent
raconter des conneries on leur dit rien
ne sont pas censurés pourrait lui on le
sent sur et après les gens te disent oui
tu entends parler des fois t'es pmp
c'est plus comme avant mais aussi plus
comme avant parce que déjà il n'ya pas
le public déjà tu fais un truc tu fais
tout de suite ne bosse pas ce que c est
quand on veut faire du malawi sinon faut
se sentir très peu mais totalement sans
fondement mais sur le format 10 x dans
ce que tu dis
j'entends des choses moi parfois sur les
plateaux qui sont beaucoup plus c'est ce
que je fais lycée will sa rétrocession à
l'état et à des idées mais chroniqueur
politique sur les émissions de deux
chaînes de chaînes de chaînes d'info qui
raconte des trucs beaucoup plus grave
que lui ils sont toujours à l'antenne on
le laisse ses des humoristes et mac
détendez vous
c'est en mai vous est-ce que tu va
réfléchir à deux fois maintenant votre
poster une vidéo tu vas dire non quand
je continue non certainement pas
certainement c'est justement j'en ai
parlé avec norman et je lui ai dit que
c'était triste mais que maintenant il
fallait réfléchir à ce qu'on va dire etc
mais moi ça va être tout le contraire je
vais là encore plus à fond par exemple
je veux qu'on m'interdise rien du tout
rien du tout vive la liberté vive le
second degré vives lui même nom et est
bien mort les cons les débiles qui
veulent juste faire du buzz et qui
veulent juste faire parler d'eux en fait
et c'est moi on peut pas passer comme ça
au dessus de saas et instagram doit
s'expliquer merci à dire que moi j'ai
regardé la vidéo je ne vois pas ce qui
est reproché
c'est la première chose et la deuxième
chose c'est qu'ils ont tous une
responsabilité les gaffes et si demain
il doit y avoir un gendarme des réseaux
sociaux c'est à eux de le financer
assure ya ces problèmes et non de ternir
ya tous les autres problèmes que l'on
connaît nos gamins ont donné ce qu'on
attend aussi c'est qu'un stade g
s'explique la surnommer accord là dessus
ou pas parce que je crois que je vais
vous dire pourquoi ils ont sanctionné
elie semoun c'est qu'il ya plusieurs
comptes qui ont dû y aller main levée de
boucliers c'est devant la levée de
boucliers de certains détails sordides
il faut qu'on sanctionne édition et on
en revient bien sûr ça fait tous le
disent un robot et il ya plein de trucs
comme ça nous on a eu le même problème
sur notre problème sachez le c'était
voilà des mecs des robots qui font des
tweets qui font des rêves et des dp
poste installé six sont que ça prend à
une ampleur incroyable et sachiez je
vous le dis qu'être plus en plus de
sociétés complètement déshumanisée et
des et des sociétés vraiment de te tele2
de médias qui payent pour avoir des
robots qui n'a fracasse telle ou telle
personne tel ou tel programme tel ou tel
homme politique tel ou tel voilà voilà
pas touche aide voilà et en fait ça se
fait aujourd'hui donc c'est ça qui est
incroyable et aujourd'hui mon grave
c'est de venir la dictature mascioli
tous les maux et toute la presse
derrière reprennent décoiffé démission
dès qu'on fait un truc il ya quatre
abrutis qui dit c'est de la merde
et bien vous allez avoir des pleins
d'articles 50 articles derrière par des
journaux qui se disent sérieux qui
manière l'émission fracasser sur les
réseaux sociaux
mais c'est qu'ils font qu'est ce qui
fait du coup qu'est ce qui t'a eridan
les risques et nous conduire là mais ça
m est intègre a stagné ou pas il
montrait intégré ou pas parce que là tu
as pris d'assaut non si de patate après
deux piges convient non non j'ai
toujours mon compte installer sur juste
supprimé la vidéo et on pas supprimer ce
jour et m'a saoulé pour régler tout ça
il faut tout simplement interdire
l'anonymat comme ça il y aurait pas tous
ces robots et ce serait impossible
et est-ce qu'on répondra nicolas c'est
juste la solution c'est d'interdire la
normale et simplement
alors ça on en a parlé plusieurs fois il
est en tout cas continue ce que tu fais
mais si tu es et tu me fascinait sourire
ce que je vais faire céder la place dans
tout bon voilà on les salue les mecs